in der cdu wird derweil weiter über das
erbe der amtierenden kanzlerin
diskutiert ja denn wenn wenn die wahlen
in bayern und hessen richtig in die hose
gehen könnte es vielleicht doch noch mal
eng werden für merkel ihre potenziellen
nachfolger bringen sich so langsam in
stellung und dazu gehört unter anderem
auch daniel günther der
ministerpräsident von schleswig holstein
der gerade den deutschlandtag der jungen
union aber mal so richtig gerockt
freunde mit einer bemerkenswerten rede
ich bin bis um halb drei in berlin im
pavillon gewesene haben getrunken die
mal bier holen du wirst schon wieder
hässlich land die hilfe blondine von
hinten er von hinten blondine von vorne
ruine abends um 22 uhr noch ins nrw
zählt und haben da rosen nach amsterdam
miteinander gesungen bierchen getrunken
das ist aufgabe von politik
[Applaus]
wir haben die rede war auf das
wesentliche und damit einer von vielen
möglichen nachfolger merkel bei übrigens
auch bei der jungen union bei diesem
deutschlandtag und alle experten waren
davon ausgegangen dass der kanzlerin da
ein ganz eisiger wind ins gesicht weht
aber es kam anders
dietmar wischmeyer
wischmeyer sehr buch der bekloppten und
bescheuerten du bist jung etwas pummelig
und mehrfach unbegabt möchtest aber
trotzdem mit leuten abhängen die total
crazy drauf sind
wenn selbst die picklige von der
gospelgruppe dich nicht haben wollen
bleibt nur noch eins die junge union
eine art lepra kolonie für junge
menschen die die welt nicht verändern
wollen
einmal im jahr treffen sich die hosen
scheißen auf ihrem deutschlandtag und
spielen revolution
hui die trauen sich was was die der
kanzlerin einfach ins gesicht schleudern
so ist lang ja eben grad schon an das
ist tradition dass auch kritische fragen
hier gestellt werden und die erste frage
stellt christian poltrock aus
schleswig-holstein ja sehr geehrte frau
bundeskanzlerin hier erstmal vielen dank
dafür dass sie heute hier sind und auch
für das was in den letzten jahren
geleistet haben für unser land aber auch
für die gesamte welt
sehr gut bei spontanem brechreiz hilft
nur ein schneller schluck wasser vorher
große fressen wegen flüchtlinge reihen
lassen und so aber kaum erscheint die
leitkuh auf der lichtung wird
hemmungslos geschlampt später haben sie
ihr sogar noch ein geschenk überreicht
dass wirklich jede frau glücklich macht
sorgen
man sieht richtig wie sie denkt wow die
schmeiße ich nachher weg eine einzige
kritische frage gab es dafür hat mutti
den nachwuchs pfeifen umgekehrt
ordentlich einen mitgegeben wegen zu
wenig mädchen im vorstand und ich sage
ihnen frauen bereichern das leben nicht
nur im privaten auch im politischen
die wissen gar nicht was ihnen entgeht
woher sollen die jungs als auch wissen
den deutschlandtag der jungen union
nennt man ja nicht umsonst den
bundeskongress der ungebremsten bekennt
frank in diesem schafstall wird niemals
ein botox heranwachsen
und wer soll die revolution auch
anführen annegret krank kalaschnikow die
ladehemmung von der saar oder jens spahn
lacht ja sogar die junge union es gibt
in unserem land noch viele harte nüsse
die wir politisch knacken müssen und als
kleines symbol und fleisch für die
echten kleinen nüsse diesen handgemacht
das ist der punkt
solange alle in der cdu um kleinere
nutzer haben als angela merkel kann ja
nichts passieren eigentlich mich wieder
hin
das logbuch der bekloppten und
bescheuerten
[Applaus]
[Musik]